our top story tonight an historic effort
in the fight against covet 19 the first
doses of the vaccine
here in nevada thank you so much for
joining us at six o'clock i'm kirsten
joyce good evening i'm brian loftis umc
started vaccinating people earlier today
the first dose is given to about 200 of
its
front line health care workers earlier
today orco mana now joining us live from
umc with more on this big day
orco
for brian and kirsten umc has made
history becoming the first hospital in
nevada
to start administering the coven 19
vaccine to some of its front-line health
care workers now this really signals
a turning point in our state's fight
against the coronavirus
the very first allocation of pfizer's
copa 19 vaccine arrived at umc this
morning
the hospital got just over 1800 doses
umc thawed some of it immediately and
began vaccinating about
200 frontline workers including staff
from the intensive care unit
the emergency department and other key
areas of the hospital
the first person to get the vaccine at
umc was actually an icu nurse
treating coven 19 patients who were told
went right back to work after getting it
the remaining doses are being stored in
the hospital's ultra cold freezer
until they're used umc ceo says they
have a distribution plan
but the focus right now is on medical
staff
nursing home patients are the most
vulnerable so uh we'll be working very
closely with the nursing home
uh community and the health district to
be able to roll that out to make sure
that we're protecting the healthcare
workers in nursing homes
but also in patients in the nursing
homes and we'll also be looking at our
patients that are in umc as well that'll
we need to get through the health care
workers first
umc expects to vaccinate close to 5 000
frontline workers
over the next seven to eight days and
some more promising news
the umc ceo says that he's confident in
the supply chain of the vaccine coming
into nevada so he actually expects
the general public to start getting
vaccinated by late january or early
february which is
earlier than previously predicted
reporting live tonight orco mana 8 news
now